you have something to say
you're down in one
another realm to do mortal combat game
Mortal Kombat X is not coming out soon
but they are starting to show more of
the game including some new modes
playing a little bit yesterday it
definitely feels like a more fluid game
to me anyway
then maybe Mortal Kombat 9 but I think
these new modes or where it's that
there's a five new factions that you get
to pick from now I guess as part of the
faction war like right when you start
like White Lotus Special Forces I think
black dragons and you got to pick that
faction and then that you kind of carry
that forward into like an online mode
that kind of builds up on a week-to-week
basis which is kind of their way of
adding a social element to the game and
kind of like stuff for you to do outside
of just like oh you just gotta fight 1v1
so it's not just that if there's
challenges and and all that yeah and
it's like you know what you do
throughout the week sort of adds up for
your team online it creates as like meta
game where let's say you know the White
Lotus players like suddenly accomplish
all this great stuff and like by the end
of the week they're the top faction the
devs were telling us that that will
unlock like special things like costumes
like maybe for just the following week
or you know maybe for as long as say
like the White Lotus holds on to its
lead but what were those 5v5 matches
again that was sort of a best-of-five
between different factions I think it
can be faction based but it can also
just be like if you want to have a
five-on-five you can have a five-on-five
I think if you just do the factions it
does add to the points again during the
week but it's you know 5 on 5 you get
different people online in their room
essentially and they go one on one head
on head and that's just how it is it's
not like if you win you get to you know
there's no advantage it's just one one
one and then at the end of it it's like
who won between the 5 to 5 it's
interesting um it's kind of one of those
things maybe even in fcc which you know
they like having those tournaments where
they have north Calvary SoCal and they
can maybe use this as as one of those or
again it's just to build up points it's
just another thing to do like an extra
that they've added but I think the
biggest layer they're adding or that
they're kind of redoing from Mortal
Kombat 9 is the living Towers
yeah like the original challenge tower
mobile combat 9 would force you to use a
certain character to go through a series
of I think 300 challenges right that
sort of added something else to the game
but players wanted more variety but they
also didn't want to be forced into
playing as specific characters right
like everyone has their favorites why
would you want to play as anyone else
so another realm has gone back they've
created what you know the living tower
system now where it's essentially always
online and it's always updated and there
are challenges that come in the form of
you know two to three day challenges
even like two to three hour long
challenges where you have to get in this
really tight window of time and and what
they do is they introduce all these
crazy mechanics right like like slow
motion or the levels tilted like 45
degrees like all this like stuff that's
supposed to disorient you but also make
the challenge new for both combatants
mm-hmm yeah I mean it's interesting to
see some of the elements they added I
kind of try to poke fun with the devs I
was saying hey I saw Sai Rex's bombs and
like I saw a rain kind of attribute
being used during these living towers
and you know of course they were like oh
no that doesn't mean that that
characters in the game we just get to
play around with doing different things
I think one of the coolest things was
having like that satellite laser that
kind of targets you and then shoots you
so you kind of have to either spaced
properly while you're doing convoys on
there get out of the way that's just one
of many things as you said that they get
to fool around with and again it adds to
your you know your faction rep again
which is like that bigger greater system
that they have but it'll be interesting
to see because they said there's gonna
be like event like bigger up and weekly
long hidden towers where it's like oh
maybe it's like an anniversary for mk or
maybe it's like Christmas and they can
do something Christmas themed or whatnot
but I mean those are the kind of things
we saw like it's pretty cool I kind of
want to see what they do to build upon
it you know it's not just a 1v1 fighter
I guess right from a player's
perspective the living tower is a great
way to keep me interested in the game
along term so often fighting games you
know rely on the online fighting
community to sort of keep interests up
among fans
now another realm is sort of taking
charge and saying that they're going to
deliver all this new content they're
gonna find ways to keep people
interested if they're that driven and
that ambitious they'll probably gonna
come up with some pretty cool stuff so
I'm looking forward to see where they
take
tower-like even over the next year